si vous pensez que les smartphones ont
vu le jour avec l'iphone vous avez tout
faux l'iphone date de 2007 le premier
téléphone intelligent lui a été inventée
quinze ans plus tôt en 1992 à l'époque
c'est le constructeur ibm qui le met au
point nom de code ibm 6 me et c'est une
petite révolution
un téléphone capable d'appeler bien sûr
mais aussi d' envoyer ou recevoir des
fax il a incarné la drees un agenda une
calculatrice on peut même jouer au
scrabble bref un téléphone que l'on peut
utiliser presque comme un ordinateur
d'où son nom or die von mais le nouvel
outil à plusieurs défauts tout d'abord
son prix plus de 1000 $ mais aussi sa
taille il mesure plus de 20 cm et pèse
plus de 500 grammes dernier souci la
batterie elle n'a qu'une heure
d'autonomie depuis évidemment les choses
ont bien changé les smartphones sont de
plus en plus puissant et endurant en
france 77 % de la population possède un
smartphone